all right so this is amazing first of
all you're following up an epic 2019
firsts on so many levels but before we
go on ahead to 2020 I want to talk about
whatever Super Bowl okay I want to talk
about the experience yeah like being up
there I mean you'd already done a lousy
already done
Coachella but being up there sharing the
stage with that money with Sakura with
JLo wasn't like it was amazing it's one
of my happiest days ever you know like
I've been waiting for a moment like this
you know like uh like Superbowl you know
to keep showing that the Latino gonna
just keep racing you know and we just
want to elevate the culture and it was
the right timing you know I'm super
grateful to be there and you know you
know we're not keep working to make more
more more moments like that yeah and so
is it you guys are doing it for the
culture you know I'm sure like I did you
rub watching Shakira that i lo and
admiring them and hug the person you
know I listen what they did yeah have
you gotten that back from your fans now
to that they see you up there doing that
I mean yeah what you know I just you
know just grateful it's just grateful
that you know what we're living now and
hopefully one day we're going to be one
half hour halftime show you know but I
think is everything to preserve process
you know like those two girls are
legends you know and and they deserve
the place they are you know so uh you
know he's keep on working and you know
let's you know this make no statements
more dreams and keep spiraling the world
yeah you've been collaborating with a
lot of amazing artists over the past
couple of years even when you're talking
about someone like JLo up Wednesdays
what do you learn from even just being
around yeah watching them work her
discipline you know the discipline it's
it's amazing how professional you know
how like how passionate are you about
what you do you know and she I I had to
show with JLo so I got to know her a
little bit more and she just in Korea
you know it can be hard working and
animation you know like it's it's such
beautiful when you understand why they
are there you know that kids and in our
humble chairs
yeah your sound reggaeton and even Latin
music in general has become more global
over the last few years you had a big
hand in that do you still feel like
there are lots of hurdles to overcome
however huh you know what thing is
everything is a process you know
anything you know we just gotta keep
working you know all the woman gotta
keep making hits you know and we keep
building you know our momentum you know
at home this is just the beginning yeah
it's just the beginning you know so it's
a new revolution when it comes to Latino
urban music you know like a tone trap
you know like we're really doing it with
a heart and people are ready to to love
what we do yeah what kind of feeling do
you get when you know that you've won
over somebody who might not have even
considered big into the music maybe
because they don't speak Spanish I loved
that when people you know they catching
the vibe yeah you know like our last two
in Europe and you know we've been in
Asia and here in stays I mean everywhere
and there's a lot of places that they
don't know what we're saying they don't
understand but with it they feel the
vibe and it's beautiful how they sing
something that they don't know what I'm
saying what they catch the by yeah I
know so it's beautiful because it's like
as change of this is our culture has
changed you know what I've been watching
other people that you know I'm getting
I'm learning Spanish because of you I
know so it's it's amazing to see that
you know something that goes beyond just
the music you know to make someone to
understand why are you actually saying
yeah is this where you saw yourself when
you were young and you were starting out
and you thought this is this is what I
want to do yeah yeah I dream I dream
about this and I and I dream about so
many other things and a kid dreaming you
know like the life without dreams
doesn't have a sense you know and uh to
me you know so you know soon as I just
left the Super Bowl I was i okay what's
the next dream you know and it doesn't
have to be professional
you know but it's something that keeps
you you know with the we want to work on
you know to be a personal thing it could
be a spiritual pain it could be you have
a family you know like sort of things
you've got at the preneur movement in a
moment so you know like it's a lot of
gems to make well what's the next dream
we use Windows who goes done yeah I
wrote it yesterday I start rolling over
that you know like I want to be doing a
sketch on SNL yeah yeah yeah if you me
like the first Latino doing you know
dust
I don't like it don't want me to be on
that and SNL sketch you know they know
you know going back to Coachella as
maybe next year you know do the Europe I
forget the name of this big festival so
that I'm thirsty what I want to do and
then I was like looking the dream to
have my my family you know to find the
right girl to have a family way you know
it's a lot of dreams you know and and
that's one of them too you know like
stop building a nice relationship is it
start with a woman that I don't know is
she you know now that I call it out to
the universe you know that's that's how
it worked and I wrote it too you know
like I wrote it
how's my dream girl you know and she
might be somewhere you know we're just
gonna build the relation which is
different but I got home and you know do
you have a family have kids and you
build another dream you that Canada you
looking so you better be out there yeah
I knew you know a Spanish is better to
you can talk to my mom it you know
[Laughter]
what's the concept here cuz every song
is a different color
yeah removing a different vibe yeah
doesn't you basically say you know I
think collars us to the universal
language as numbers as music yeah
you know and in this one I wanted to do
I wanted to make a district that are
different fresh you know
like go back to Michael Jackson styles
where the videos were out of this world
or something just like different and
unique you know and I just do the
regular videos of a girl shaking the red
which is good too
I respect that as much part of the
culture you know but I wanted to go
beyond that you know I want to connect
to the people in a different way you
know one of people that be like wow do
you see what he did you see the light is
there you see the the colors do you see
this thing of that you know they want
people to see and to watch over and over
again our videos and we and finally
these different details that we have and
how to elevate I want to win something
in Cannes you know in Canada you know
like go go go even beyond the music you
know keep connecting with people that
were you know I have this collaboration
with Murakami you know and you know I
want just like the kids to get to know
more about art you know it's all like a
lifestyle you know you know you know I
just want to change the game with the
new Jordan ones that are coming up to
you know like it's just like inspiring
and and and make a change no smarter you
say no